- My next guest knows all too well
what it's like to work
for the Royal household.
He's the former royal butler
to His Royal Highness,
Prince Charles and Camilla
the Duchess of Cornwall.
Please welcome Mr. Grant Harold, y'all.
(applause)
- [Kelly] I mean, what was it like
when you first met Prince
Charles and Camilla?
- It was, it was, quite nerve-wracking
in fact, I wasn't sure what
the, what the protocol was,
what you're supposed to do,
what you're not supposed to do.
And the confession I have to make
is that I was in Scotland,
there's this long corridor,
and they appeared at the end
of the corridor and I panicked.
And I remember thinking, what do you do?
Can you speak to them? Can
you, do you not speak to them?
(laughter)
And there was a, there was a
door on the right hand side,
so I thought, I'll went in that room,
and I'll keep away for a minute
or two until they go past.
Unfortunately, it wasn't a
room, it was a storage cupboard.
(laughter)
- Did they think you were nuts?
- [Grant] Yes. They did.
(laughter)
- [Grant] Because, there was
actually glass and bottles
and so I thought, they're
gonna think I'm an, uh, uh..
- [Kelly] ...alcoholic!
- [Grant] ...alcoholic! Yeah, exactly.
And I kinda stood there
and the next thing I heard
was the Prince going, oh,
do you think he's okay?
(laughter)
- [Kelly] (gasps)
- [Grant] And, I thought,
right, I better walk out.
- [Kelly] (laughs)
- [Grant] So I opened the
door and I tried to be
very professional and I
didn't make eye contact
and there was a door on the other side,
so I opened the door on the other side
praying it wasn't another cupboard.
And it was a staircase, and
I remember kind of going,
ah, the staircase.
And then they looked at me and went,
good morning your Royal Highnesses.
(laughter)
And then carried on, and
luckily they started laughing.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh,
(laughter)
- [Kelly] That's amazing!
(applause)
All right well let's talk some tea, like,
Hugh gave me a lot of crap, man.
I'm just saying Grant, okay?
But how did we do today?
Silver? We have silver.
- [Grant] So this is wonderful.
- [Kelly] How have we done?
- [Grant] This is great, and you've got,
is that a silver... is
that a silver teaspoon?
- [Kelly] Yeah, I will say though,
I know that y'all don't like bags, right?
You like loose leaf.
'Cause I do too.
- Well, bags are very, yeah, not
(mumbles)
- [Kelly] Okay. Posh, party of one.
(laughter)
- And you've got the lemon
which is, I've got to watch
because I am sitting next
to country western royalty.
- [Kelly] I know.
- So I've got to kind of make sure I
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
(applause)
Um, and we've got the lemon
so if it's an Earl Grey
um, I assume this is Earl Grey tea.
- [Kelly] I love Earl Grey.
- [Grant] So, oh, fantastic.
- [Kelly] Would you like to try it?
- Oh, have you, have you...?
- [Kelly] I've already - yeah,
I've... would you like to...
I will take some more, sir.
- Do you want me to - is
that okay? - we haven't got
a tea strainer, have we? No.
- [Kelly] I'm totally gonna
tell everyone that you, like,
did this for royalty and then me.
(laughter)
- [Kelly] That makes me
so much cooler to myself.
(laughter)
- Oh, do you want some,
do you want some lemon?
- [Kelly] No, I like it plain.
- Okay, you're sure?
- Oh no, yeah, lemon is great.
(laughter)
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
- You don't have to do that, you don't!
- [Kelly] Yes, I love lemon.
- [Grant] You should love lemon
(laughter)
you should.
- Love lemon.
- Lovely.
- Yeah. Maybe like, I
mean, let's just get sugar
while we're at it. We're
growing, it's fine.
- Sugar?
- No?
- No.
- [Kelly] What?
- You don't use sugar in Earl Grey.
- [Kelly] No?
- No it's...
(scoffs)
(laughter)
- [Kelly] Why is it there?
- Wait, what?
(applause)
- [Grant] On this occasion I wouldn't.
Not with, uh...
- No, me neither!
I'm so steady.
(laughter)
- Yes, just one more little thing.
Have you not got like a, um...
- Oh! Yeah, there, okay.
- No, no, no.
- [Kelly] Er, no.
(laughter)
- Excuse me, excuse me.
(applause)
- I'm very fancy, Grant!
- We need the saucer.
- [Lesley] Oh yeah, the saucer!
- [Kelly] Today I'm
bringing the class, Grant.
- So... yes, I can tell, lovely
(laughter)
So, what we're gonna do, is,
you're gonna do a very gentle
back and forward motion.
And what you don't do
(clinking)
'cause we're not in a band or whatever.
And then you place it on the side.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Grant] So, how would you do this bit?
How would you pick it up?
- Okay. How would I pick it up?
- How would you pick the cup up?
- Oh, well, by the tea thing?
- Are you okay there?
(laughter)
- And then with a pinky?
- I'm just like getting
ready to dance, Grant.
(laughter)
(applause)
- This is how Americans do it.
I just spilt it on myself.
(applause)
- No wait, what do you...
- So you...
- That was a workout!
(laughter)
- You might need...
- Oh, sure.
- So you can keep that.
- I'm never gonna make
it as a royal, it's over.
- No, it's fine.
But I did notice you
kind of seem to kind of
pick it up with two, um, hands.
- Sometimes I do.
- Just to reassure you, nobody's gonna
steal it from you, dear.
- You know what, you ain't
aware of where I'm from.
(laughter)
- Well, so, what you do is, you pick it up
the whole thing together.
- Okay.
- And then we pick it up with the handle.
We don't stick the pinkies out.
We're not testing the wind direction.
- Are you even thirsty at this point?
(laughter)
- Isn't it exciting? It's riveting.
- I've got my pinky.
- No, no pinky's in, you're
not testing the wind direction.
- Pinky in, pinky in.
- We're not doing the weather forecast.
- [Kelly] That's not a...
- That's a myth, it's a myth. It's a myth.
- [Grant] Absolutely, it's a myth.
- Oh, totally.
I just brought it up
so we could, you know,
tell everybody it's a myth.
- [Lesley] Yeah.
(laughter)
- [Grant] And then when we
drink, what we don't do,
we don't go
(slurps)
- [Lesley] Well you don't do that.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Grant] We do it very, very...
- No, we don't slurp.
- [Grant] No, none of
that. So it's very gentle.
- Like a lady.
Are you doing it like a lady?
- It's delicious.
It's slightly cold.
- [Kelly] It is.
Well, it's been a minute.
The show's been on a minute.
(laughter)
- But it is delicious.
So that's kind of how you, how you do it.
And you'd have some sandwiches.
I notice there were square sandwiches.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yes, that was lovely.
- I am going to invite you to my barn
and we're gonna have tea there.
(laughter)
- Your barn?
- A barn.
- Oh, can't wait.
(laughter)
- [Kelly] And then we're
gonna put you on a horse
Western style!
And then you're gonna go barrel
racing with Ms. McEntire.
(laughter)
- That I'd like to see!